une session plénière après trois
allocutions une brillante fait par les
dirigeants de différents ministères dans
notre pays surtout la dernière
intervention de monsieur narychkine qui
nous en faut générer des différentes
idées et j'y pense qu à la suite de
cette conférence annuelle du ministère
de la défense nous allons reprendre les
discussions si on les sujets sains
entamée par les speakers précédent alors
votre sujet d'aujourd'hui c'est
l'afrique et le moyen orient les
questions de sécurité peureux n'ai pas
abusé d autres temps mais je ne tiens à
souligner un point qui élimina est lié
avec les interventions précédentes et
qui est franchement unis avec cette
discussion qui est animée dans le monde
entier compte tenu de la teneur du
contexte pandémique et ses conséquences
et son influence se développement
ultérieur de l'humanité la pandémie n'a
pas bouleversement de a eu rien de
nouveau de tout à fait nouveau la
pandémie n'a fait que des pistes et il
en a fait qu'apparaître les tendances
qui ont déjà été signalés pendant les
conférences du mouscou ya plusieurs
années de suite ça jouait le rôle de
catalyseur pour faire apparaître les
tendances qui auparavant n'était pas au
centre de notre attention long de ce
processus ce qui ne date pas d'hier mais
qu'est devenu plus évident est plus
présent grâce à la pandémie
ce que le monde n'a plus de zones
périphériques
alors je vais pas vous cacher cet effet
non à un habitant dans les pays
développés de l'hémisphère nord
nous avons cette tendance à penser que
la politique est mondiale avec joueur de
centre ça veut dire l'espace où les
majeures événement s'est passé est elle
la périphérie où les événements pouvait
avoir quelques en partance mais restait
toujours les dérivés mais ce qui se
passe au centre
alors maintenant cette position hautaine
n'est plus volages valable parce que le
monde est uni est unique et intrus il
dit de façon très forte à la pandémie
1 a fait preuve encore une fois d'une
façon nous ne sommes fragmenté pour la
le confinement mais on reste entre liés
les uns aux autres là on trouve plus de
la périphérie on trouve plus des zones
de second plan
tous les événements qui se passent
lecteurs dans le monde ont de
l'importance égale tous les continents
apportent leur contribution puissante
développement mondial les régions aux
plus grandes régions deviennent des
acteurs globaux notre sujet
d'aujourd'hui qui concerne le moyen en
rien qui reste au centre de la
préoccupation depuis longtemps et même
al
à cet égard les processus devient
deviennent de plus en plus indépendants
c'est nos dépens
plus d opinion externe c'est le moyen
orient lui même qui commence générer les
questions qui nécessitent de les
réactions du monde quand il est
évidemment l'afrique est récent
continent un très important du point de
vue des perspectives du développement
mondial et la fille qui reprend le
premier plein alors il y au passé on a
beaucoup parlé de ce que l'afrique qui
reste d'un espace de concurrence des
acteurs extérieurs
bon la concurrence ça reste c'est
évident mais le monde devient de plus en
plus démocratique et non pas si
démocratique que les américains le
veulent et l'ont voulu il ya une
vingtaine d'années non en fait la
démocratie actuelle secure les voit la
volonté des peuples de différents pays
ont plus d'importance et sont prononcés
à la haute voix qui ne laisse pas à la
possibilité de les faire ignorer
l'époque you kill quand dans au centre
du monde prenait des décisions 1 qui
avait des conséquences dans la
périphérie ça n'existe plus comme un
cinglé narychkine viande de dire le
monde s'habitue peu à vivre au sens du
money et ça c'est merveilleux c'est
merveilleux parce que ça arrive plus
naturel que la structure de paravent
mais cette façon de s'y habituer
justement du ca nous allons parler
aujourd'hui concernant le moyen orient
et l'afrique
nos avons
des panélistes merveilleux je remercie
personnellement tous ceux qui sont venus
mon obstant des menace de l'aco vide on
voit longtemps on encore naviguer sur
ces vagues de la maladie il faut s'en
rendre compte et ils font faire face
c'est avec plaisir que je passe la
parole à notre invité notre ami algérien
générale de corse général de corps de
l'armée algérienne vice-ministre de la
défense said chante shon et gris si le
playboy parole
c'est une raïs
et voici dette mesdames et messieurs
vont vite où j'y tiens vous adresser ma
reconnaissance s'en sert pour
l'organisation de cette conférence qui
reste une plateforme importante pour les
changes depuis nyon pour des questions
sécuritaires dans les régions et
notamment sa pour les pays asiatiques a
pris les pays du moyen orient pour
atteindre l'entente mutuelle dans le
contexte fait des défis actuels à la
sécurité et à la défense visant à
informer de nouveaux mécanismes de up
côté retiens je tiens à vous exprimer ma
profonde me confondre remerciements pour
votre présence à cet événement
d'importance qui démontre le
renforcement de la sécurité régionale
mesdames et messieurs votre excellence
monsieur le président dans le contexte
international et régional connaît des
mutations géopolitiques complexe et
multidimensionnel qui sont à l'origine
de l'émergence de nouveaux défis et
menace ayant effectué la sécurité et la
paix au niveau de notre sphère régionale
en effet même si les menaces et les
risques de conflits armés entre des
acteurs étatiques et conventionnelles la
mine ont été contenus il n'en demeure
pas moins que tu les menaces
contemporaines à son transfrontalière
est souvent lié à des acteurs non
étatiques
vous serez d'accord avec moi de
reconnaître que la menace est devenu du
fuse multiforme et sournoise le constat
prix vaut également pour le continent
africain en général
en l'espace c'est le sait rien et
maghrib maghrébins en particulier cette
région subit en fait les affres du
terrorisme du trafic d'armes et de
drogue de la traite humaine
les menaces cybernétiques et des autres
crime organisé transfrontalier ajoutant
cela des conséquences du dérèglement
climatique se matérialisant par des
épisodes météorologiques sévères des
stress hydriques et des menaces de
famine et de flux migratoires sans
précédent liée à ces bouleversements
climatiques
de surcroît d'autres facteurs
déstabilisateurs tels que les risques
pandémiques
les conflits entre communautaires et les
exode des populations fuyant les régions
marquées par la violence ainsi que la
précarité de la population alimente la
crise sécuritaire caractérisant cette
région
cette situation sécuritaire des les
terres est un grave et l'incapacité de
certains états à faire face efficacement
à ces menaces qui continuent ce produit
ferrer sur l'ensemble du continent
afrique en présentant six planer des
risques sécuritaires les normes pour les
peuples africains à court et moyen terme
cette perspective sécuritaire
hypothéquera les chances de
de l'ogm ans au niveau du continent et
ouvrira la voie aux ingérences
étrangères à ce prétexte d' efforts de
stabilisation des ventes ayant basculé
dans la violence parfois d'une façon
carrément d'anticiper l'espace c'est le
sait rien n'échappe à cette logique de
détérioration de la situation
sécuritaire en effet le sel se trouve
impactée par l'ensemble de semaine et le
fluo que je viens d'évoquer conjuguée à
l'instabilité politique chronique de
certains états de cet espace
elle est aussi à souligner que les
retombées de la crise en libye et les
interventions étrangères dont se fit on
te départ a fait basculer la sécurité et
la stabilité n'a certains pays du sel
c'est dans une seconde étape ont
contribué à pérenniser la
déstabilisation existantes dans la sous
région à travers notamment le trafic
d'armes et de drogués et la présence des
milices fortement armés dans cette
espèce dans les messieurs chers
présidents
dans ce contexte sécuritaire
caractérisant l'espace c'est le sérieux
est maghrébin ces greffes la résurgence
du conflit armé au sahara occidental et
de suite à la violation le 13 novembre
2020 car le maroc de l'accord du
cessez-le-feu qui plus est l'impasse 1,1
enregistrée dans le règlement de ce
conflit sur la base des résolutions des
nations unies elle a pacifié la
passivité de certains membres du conseil
de sécurité internationale a désigné un
représentant spécial du secrétaire
général de l'onu ont favorisé la reprise
des hostilités entre la république
démocratique
le maroc et le sahara occidental est la
dernière colonie en afrique dont le
peuple aspire à s'exprimer librement sur
son autodétermination il a maintes fois
fait valoir que les agissements de
l'occupant présente a annexé par la
force aux lèves territoire sahraoui et à
évacuer la notion de l'observation des
droits de l'homme dans les territoires
occupés sont contraires à la charte des
nations unies et à la constitutif de
l'union africaine dont les république
arabe sahraouie démocratique et est un
membre fondateur
cette situation alarmante empreinte de
risque d'escaladé militaire et
d'intervention extrait régional est en
mesure d'en brise d'embraser toute les
régions
cette perspective fortement
préoccupantes pour la paix et la
sécurité
interpelle la communauté internationale
à prendre ses responsabilités pour se
conformer au droit international dans la
résolution de cette crise où
l'expérience exige à part mon pays
particulièrement en matière de lutte
contre le terrorisme a constitué une
référence pour l'ensemble des pays de la
sous région pour atteindre les objectifs
sécuritaires nécessaires à la
stabilisation et la promotion de l'apce
et du développement ainsi et pour
relever les défis sécuritaires mon pays
à adopter une stratégie
multidimensionnelle ayant préservé
l'algérie des menaces prévost lance dans
son voisinage des résidus du terrorisme
en termes laquelle stratégie est en basé
sur les aspects politiques militaires
saucier connaît bien que religieuse
éducationnel et informationnels
cette stratégie a également pris en
considération les mesures concrètes et
anticipative due essentiellement au
développement du contexte sécuritaire
régionale traduite par lé renforcement
conséquent et l'adaptation des
dispositifs opérationnels déployés par
l'armée nationale populaire et les
services de sécurité pour la
sécurisation des longues frontières
terrestres contre l'instabilité qui
prévaut dans la région
de plus l'algérie fidèle aux fondements
de sa politique extérieure continue
comme elle l'a toujours fait à agir pour
la restauration de la stabilité politico
sécuritaire dans la sous région
particulièrement au mali et en ligne
basé essentiellement sur la non
ingérence étrangère le dialogue inclusif
la sauvegarde de l'intégrité
territoriale et la cohésion nationale à
ce titre l'algérie a appelé et alger et
agit pour fédérer les efforts des pays
de la région en particulier et de
l'union africaine en général dans cette
optique à mon pays à oeuvrer pour
abriter dynamiser le comité d'état major
opérationnel conjoint dédié à l'échangé
de renseignements et de la coordination
des actions de part de l'autre des
frontières de l'ue n'était fusion à
l'unité fusion liaison ufl dédié au
partage des informations entre les
services sécurité des pays concernés
comme la bri si le centre africain pour
les études et les recherches sur le
terrorisme
certes il est clair qu'une prise en
charge et fils et efficiente des
différences menace passe inéluctablement
par une gestion de crise compte certes
et devant les hypothèses d'action
privilégié les approches nationales et
régionales et ce dans le respect du
droit international à ce propos mon pays
a toujours fait montre de son empire
dispensés disponibilité à contribuer à
l'effort international de lutte contre
le terrorisme notamment entre ailleurs
son engagement aux côtés de ses voisins
pour leur permettre de renforcer leurs
capacités militaires en vue de faire
face aux défis sécuritaires car nous
sommes persuadés que la sécurité de nos
voisins est aussi la nôtre
monsieur madame honorable résistance
partant de ce constat il le serait
primordiale d'asseoir à une synergie et
d'apporter des réponses communes défi
pour assurer la sécurité la stabilité et
la prospérité régionales
il nous appartient de mener en premier
priorité le combat rude filles contre la
menace terroriste et les crimes
transfrontaliers
tout en consolidant la bonne gouvernance
et les missions institutionnelles des
états par lasser motion ou des
triptyques sécurité paie et
développement enfin je vous assure de
l'entière disponibilité de l'algérie à
oeuvrer avec ses partenaires pour faire
face aux défis sécuritaires que connaît
la communauté internationale notamment
dans la région maghrébine et sahel
seriez main ce en développant des
mécanismes de coopération nécessaires à
cet effet dans le respect de la légalité
internationale merci pour votre
attention s'il vous plaît merci beaucoup
je chers collègues votre pays de fait
votre pays dispose d'une expérience
tragique et unique malheureusement
surtout pendant les années 80 dit c'est
pas ce que l'algérie était là premier
pays qui a fait face à la première vague
et de fête
actuellement l'algérie sort le garant de
stabilité dans toutes les régions du
nord de l'afrique merci beaucoup d'avoir
partager votre expérience et je suis sûr
que cette expérience sera très attaquées
mans attendu par tous maintenant je suis
fier de passer la parole à notre
intervenants suivants le vice président
de la république guinée équatoriale et
messieurs gaga merci beaucoup c'est à
vous la parole
ces imbécilités l'initient markaris
monsieur le président de la session cher
dirigeant de délégation participant à
cette conférence
chers invités mesdames et messieurs
permettez moi de commencer mon
intervention lors de cette conférence
sur la sécurité internationale et qui se
tient dans cette formidable ville de
moscou malgré une grande menace sérieuse
à la santé de la population
résultant de la pandémie de l'afp
8 19 kako vers le monde entier pendant
les deux ans dernier et dans ce contexte
un autre riom félicité le gouvernement
de la fédération de russie avec
l'initiative prévoyant la tenue de ce
grand événement important afin de
résoudre l'une des questions les plus
importantes est fondamental comme le
développement harmonieux des relations
entre nos états aussi bien que la
possibilité de discuter du façon sincère
ouverte cette question sensible qui
suscite un intérêt global comme la paix
et la sécurité internationales et dans
ce contexte andrillon exprimer notre ne
remerciements au gouvernement russe aida
vouloir inviter l'air est ce que tu la
guinée équatoriale
parmi eux
il est invité elle est plus un honorable
et non de lyon aussi remercier aussi
pour un accueil spiritualité
traditionnelle du peuple russe bien
congrès mesdames messieurs la réalité
face à laquelle nous trouvons ce quart
temps 10 par une situation extrêmement
complexe dans l'histoire de l'humanité à
cause de la menace à la santé de la
population du terrorisme conflit armé
changement climatique piratage
criminalité la france compte frontalière
le caractère non protégés des réseaux
informatiques les prolifération des
armes mbc et des crises économiques
aussi bien que des défis à la sécurité
non traditionnelles qui devient de plus
en plus par l'umq est considérable qui
on ne met en situation de faire le choix
et surtout pour renforcer la coopération
multilatérale pour adopter atteindre les
objectifs de développement durable
prévue par l'agent de développement
durable de l'onu à l'horizon jusqu'à
2030 vient sur la tenue de cet événement
favorise une discussion approfondie des
différentes calamités à qui privera le
continent africain sur tous les états de
la zone de ça elle est évidemment la
région de l'afrique centrale les régions
où se trouve mon pays comme la guinée
équatoriale peut avoir le même destin
aussi des mesures de prévention compte
tenu des problèmes dans le dos loin de
l'essai qui aurait été parce qu'elle est
il se trouve ne sera pas prise bien sûr
nous considérons que la politique
globale moderne doit viser non seulement
pour assurer la promotion des triomphes
et les industriels et des puissances
laideur mais aussi il faut avouer y
reconnaître le fonctionnement estimé les
efforts des pays les moins développés en
tant que mécanisme de stimulation
morales contenu de l'aspiration pour
prévenir les conflits surtout à la
participation au forum et internationaux
pour trouver des consensus concernant
les problèmes de la sécurité
internationales pour cette raison la
république de la guinée et matériels
considère ce que le conseil de sécurité
des nations unies mme doit servir du
noyau de ce mécanisme de sécurité
collective et doit élargir ses pouvoirs
doit prendre plus de responsabilités
appliquer plus des cours et je vais un
reflux important pour assurer la paix et
la sécurité internationales
évidemment ces actions doivent être
réalisés en étroite coopération avec
d'autres structures et forme qui on
partage la même objectif
et comme l'a fait représente une
aspiration universelle de toute
l'humanité
le conseil de sécurité de voir respecter
ce principe basique et qui prévoit tout
d'abord le règlement pacifique des
conflits sur tous les axes par
l'intermédiaire des outils diplomatiques
et y compris le dialogue et les
négociations les discussions parce que
c'est vraiment le seul outil et procédés
possible efficace compte y avait la paix
durable compte tenu des objectifs et des
principes de la charte des nations unies
malheureusement malgré le fait que la
majorité des opérations de maintien de
la paix sous l'égide des nations unies a
déployé en afrique
nous constatons et nous voyons la
croissance des conflits continuent sur
notre continent et dans ce contexte nous
voudrions profiter de cette possibilité
pourrait exprimer notre envie encore une
fois pour envisager la possibilité d'une
réforme urgente du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu pour que l'afrique soit capable
d'utiliser sa représentation permanente
pour et avoir sa propre voix afin de
participer aux discussions de
négociations et à l'adoption des
décisions sous l'égide et de cet
organisme responsable
autrement dit à le conseil de sécurité
doit être adaptée aux réalités du monde
contemporain
évidemment la guinée équatoriale
reconnaît et félicite à les espoirs est
un rôle actif
que les riches fédération de russie joue
dans le but de renforcer la paix la
sécurité et la stabilité dans le monde
entier et en particulier en afrique
la russie n'a pas non seulement assurer
le soutien nécessaire alpes pour
l'afrique dans la mise en place et dans
la création d état libre et indépendant
pendant la période coloniale mais
jusqu'à présent des initiatives
heureuses sur le continent africain joue
un rôle important et profite de
l'adoption et vise assuré et atteindre
la paix la stabilité et la sécurité que
l'afrique attend avec impatience de
nombreux états africains subi des
conséquences de ses complices de
différent au niveau sur différents axes
main grâce à la russie ses prix
atteignent la stabilité dont le gens ont
toujours rêvé
d'autant plus la russie a fait une
grande contribution dans l'aspiration de
l'afrique vers la prospérité à travers
le programme de la formation académique
de plusieurs générations d air frais
gains donc
nos nombreuses représentant je suis sûr
font partie de nos délégations n'y a pas
d'autre moyen pour nous utilisons les
autres pour faire face aux difficultés
de la vie
ce que la russie a déjà fait pour
l'afrique et tout cnl raison permet de
considérer la russie en tant que
partenaire important pour leur fric en
même temps l'instar des relations
amicales fraternelles et stratégique
pour la prix dans l'ensemble est bien
sûr pour la guinée équatoriale en
particulier cher participant à la
confiera ce mesdames et messieurs
ces dernières années la guinée
équatoriale et est devenu victime de
plusieurs attaques des pirates d'origine
douteuse surtout dans le golfe de guinée
en plus de nombreuses états africains
sous trouve sous la menace des
mercenaires et des forces externes qui
vise à déstabiliser des pouvoirs
constitutionnels et formés sur une base
légale et surtout la situation d'absence
de sécurité de stabilité dans le golfe
de guinée où l'activité des pirates a
augmenté il suscite la préoccupation
nécessite l'attention de thann où tout
ça afin de chercher trouver la solution
finale compte tenu de l'importance de
cette région pour le transport maritime
aussi et surtout pour l'économie
mondiale
nous apprécions l'assistance la
solidarité c'est la bonne volonté que la
russie démontre sur aux intérêts des
pays africains pour former et réunir
s'efforçait et qui vise non seulement à
alléger de chaque semaine
je suis accélérer le rétablissement post
conflit à atteindre un développement
économique social et pour améliorer la
vie des peuples en respectant les
principes de non ingérence dans les
affaires internes de nos états nous
agissons pour une coexistence pacifique
une confiance mutuelle en avant la
coopération mutuellement avantageuse
une attitude est équilibré et nous
travaillons dans le but de construire un
monde harmonieux dans les conditions de
stabilité et prospérité universel parce
que nous mais non la politique de non
ingérence aux affaires internes d'autres
pays dans le domaine de la défense
nationale est pour cette raison contenu
du respect mutuel et du fait que nous
coopérons avec et des états amicaux et
fraternelle dans le cadre de
l'élaboration la mise en place de
stratégies qui favorise la paix et la
stabilité sociale ne connaissons que
dans les conditions d'absence de la paix
on peut pas atteindre un minot
développement ni le programme nous
proposons notre nom à la fédération de
russie que nous considérons comme pays
amical allié fiable et partenaire
stratégique qui a une grande expérience
dans ce domaine et dans ce contexte
j'aimerais rassurer mon ami monsieur son
excellent sergueï choïgou que dire
aujourd'hui demain et toujours la russie
et la communauté internationale peuvent
toujours compter sur la guinée
équatoriale son peuple
sur son président obiang nguema mbasogo
dans l'esprit du renforcement ultérieur
des relations d'amitié de coopération
qui ont toujours émis nos gouvernements
dans la lutte contre les pauvres voter
quelle âme et et qui résulte de
l'absence de la sécurité internationale
maintenant à conclusion je vous souhaite
à vous tous des succès merci beaucoup de
votre attention
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur de
vice-président pour de très bonnes
paroles chaleureuses à l'attention de
russie surtout le fait que vous avez
reste sur un couac fois de soutenir ses
relations et ses aspirations et surtout
vous avez touché une question
extrêmement sensible surtout concernant
la représentation des des états au
niveau du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
ainsi que dieu par ne comprenons qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses qui ont changé
depuis 75 ans est ce pour cette raison
il faut situer les uns autre approche
parlera pour la représentation
d'autres états et comme un sergueï
lavrov a déjà dit dans son allocution la
stabilité du conseiller de sécurité
c'est une garantie n'est plus sûr de la
garantie de stabilité dans le monde
entier mais quand même il faut chercher
de nouvelles approches parce que le nu
en tant que corps organismes et vision
doit se développer évoluer merci
beaucoup d'avoir coché ce sujet je
maintenant je suis ravi de transmettre
la parole au général de division qui
représente la mauritanie aujourd'hui ici
merci beaucoup
votre excellence et à vous la parole
pendant de dieu le clément et le
miséricordieux
je remercie de ses donneurs qui n'a pas
l'intention de participer à cette
conférence d'aujourd'hui pour parler de
la coopération militaire technique et
entre la russie et les pays d'afrique et
du moyen rien je vais parler aux sujets
les plus importants concernant les défis
sécuritaires en afrique et au moyen rien
ce qui nous impose d'allergie le cercle
des partenaires acteurs à la cause de
sécurité régionale je parlerai que la
nécessité de la reprise de la
coopération bilatérale avec les russies
la coopération multilatérale dans les
cadres favorables à la poursuite de
congré développement mondial mesdames et
messieurs vont tout je tiens profiter de
cette opportunité pour vous venu parler
de l'expérience positive de leur dire
que cela nous de mauritanie sous la
gestion sage de notre président notre
pays et elle reste un pays qui a connu
le développement de différentes cultures
et différentes civilisations ceux qui
n'en paient ont dialogué multiculturelle
en y basant à des valeurs universelles
de la paix de la sécurité nous
réaffirmons la nécessité deux années de
contreterrorisme ans la prolifique à
sion prolifération des armes contre la
traite humaine et tout sûr de
criminalité organisée transfrontalière
il est à noter que la sécurité
internationale souffre le plus souvent à
cause de l'incapacité des institutions
démocratiques de faire face à des
menaces actuelles dans de nombreux pays
les la jeunesse prend à la légère la
stuation influencée de l'extérieur et
s'associer à des milieux terroristes qui
profitent des 15 ans du système éducatif
de certains pays mais terroriste
prétexte leur actualité
en supposant la religion tandis que leur
activité n'a rien de comment oser
les valeurs éternelles proclamée par les
doctrines et saint saëns les infos
reçues ni de cinq pays de celle soutenue
par plusieurs pays dont la france les
états unis la chine le royaume de
l'arabie saoudite les émirats arabes
unis espagne et autres il faut 2 6
mentionné nos alliés stratégiques qui
est qui combattent ensemble avec nous et
nous aident à combattre le terrorisme
j'y tiens à attirer votre attention
l'expérience positive que détient la
mauritanie et dans le domaine de la
lutte contre le terrorisme et
l'extrémisme
nous avons su trouver de vraies causes
des menaces sécuritaires des lacunes qui
ont servi de base pour former le concept
sécuritaire en se basant à des principes
religieux à juridiques et sociaux tous a
permis aux deux accélérée là les efforts
aux et renforcer nos forces armées à
maîtriser les sources de financement du
terrorisme et des neutraliser mesdames
et messieurs les relations entre la
russie et les prises de l'afrique
moyen orient sont traditionnellement
forte
vu la position géographique
en 2005 la fédération de russie est à
dire en tant qu observateur dans l'union
africaine le temps de l'union soviétique
et la coopération de militaires en a été
réalisée dans le cadre du la cour de
l'assistance était cailloux qui est de
la formation militaire
ensuite est la diplomatie russe et
grinçant au président poutine a repris à
son efficacité et sa présence à la
russie dans une puissance nucléaire
avec son statut de membre permanent de
pensée de sécurité de l'onu à porter sa
forte contribution avec aux de la lutte
contre le terrorisme dans les rues 6
juillet de la confiance de la part de
ses alliés grâce on sent son rôle actif
dans les milieux à décisionnaires à
l'échelle mondiale du domaine politique
économique financière ensemble est clair
que s'il faut unir nos efforts pour
assurer la paix la sécurité dans
différentes régions du monde afin de
former les conditions favorables au
développement social et économique des
peuples du globe
mesdames et messiers l'autre d'essence
de conflits ethniques et l'extrémisme
qui relève la tête
laufon a refusé nos stratégies et nos
capteurs politique de coopération à
l'échelle mondiale actuellement est
salée en nécessaire d'écrire un nouveau
système de procuration entre étatique
qui a en dise le nier en tant qu
mobilisation cadre nécessite une
profonde réforme à sion qui prendrait en
compte les modifications de l état de
choses actuelles pour conclure je peux
dire que la création d'un monde
multipolaire équilibré et unie autour
des missions stratégiques cohen pourrait
servir de garantie à la restauration de
la paix de la sécurité dans des branches
de l'afrique du moyen orient et du monde
entier
que le dieu bénisse et je vous remercie
de votre attention
je remercie monsieur le ministre je vois
que les sujets de l'onu passe religieux
rouge à travers nos interventions je
pense qu'il peut être durant la séance
de conférences et faudra en parler plus
en détail mais en ce qui concerne la
santé votre intervention évidemment vous
avez entonné une question à primordial
puisque le monde est multipolaire qui
est un contrepoids à l'hégémonie c'est
mon désir
il est là mais les rues de ce modèle
mondial sassine sa part pas de du
bonheur ça change la dame seulement
l'état équilibrée de ce monde
multipolaire c'est ça ce qu'il faut
aspirer
mais comment le frère sont le sait pour
le moment on s'efforce qui les épées
schéma que nous trouvons dans notre
histoire de dix neuvième siècle
peut-être avant la seconde guerre
mondiale mais on n'arrivera pas à le
faire parce que le monde a beaucoup
changé c'est un sujet apparaît très
intéressant
mais qui méritent d'être discutées
jurassien parole en participant
permanent de la conférence en partenaire
pierre de la confiance
messier p terme envers président du
comité international de la croix rouge
s'il vous plaît potter merci beaucoup
vos excellences mesdames et messieurs
chers collègues je tiens à remercier le
ministère de la défense pour la deuxième
opportunité de m'exprimer madre sans
savon participants de cette conférence
et lustres comme j'ai déjà dit hier
toutes les tentatives entreprises par le
comité régional du coin rouge et vise à
stabiliser la situation et à réduire les
problèmes probables liés avec des
conflits existants et 10 mai dont je
vais vous parler de ce qui fait notre
comité au moyen orient et en afrique
sans heurts le sujet d'aujourd'hui est
très important lorsqu'il s'agit de la
situation régionale
il était dans culte de la croix rouge
est sesat analyser les oreilles de
problèmes qui nous restent évidemment
sont nombreuses les rats climie
l'affichage de seconde la corde qu'elle
n'est ainsi de suite
les zones à problème sont nombreuses
nous sommes unis peur les points communs
par magie dit on trouve aussi des défis
supplémentaires qui à part les conflits
contribuer à déstabiliser les situations
tout d'abord il s'agit de la
fragmentation de notre société et la
présentation de nos territoires la
transformation numérique qui n'est pas
venu dans tous les pays pour le moment
la politisation des hostilités des
conflits armés en hommes en armes et
c'est au conseil serait de ses preuves
massif de ces problèmes nous ressentons
le besoin qu'une aide humanitaire et le
comité international de croix rouge
focalise ses efforts à 70 % de son
budget à ces régions dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui cette région dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui
saleh en toute logique étant donné que
dans la région on trouve une grande
quantité des filles qui subissent ses
deux filles concentrés dans les mêmes
pour tous les pays de la région et
l'état disant tu le comité des
ressources du croix rouge
là où on a vraiment besoin d'une aide
humanitaire avant tout pour aider les
civils
le moyen orient et l'afrique reste une
zone sensible et très compliqué pour
nous il est évident qu on y trouve
beaucoup de violences beaucoup de
conflits sans oublier le changement que
les changements climatiques la pauvreté
décrit les déficiences de toutes sortes
de la fragilité des systèmes économiques
longueur locaux alors le comité
international de la croix rouge et
travaille en reliant cantine avec les
militaires la police avec toutes sortes
du groupement militaire afin de protéger
les vies la dignité des gens le sim des
conflits nombre elles ont des stages de
formation de planning pour faciliter
notre tâche durant ces derniers le
comité international de pois rouge après
les et plus de 206 9 2006 en événements
avec l'implication de plusieurs milliers
de personnels et en laissant retrait et
pays notre présence la majorité de ces
opérations ont été réalisées au moyen
orient et l'afrique
nonobstant les restitutions pandémie
nous avons su le faire durant l'année
passée
à ces zones direction prévoit avant tout
la présence d'une quantité importante de
différents spécialistes et représentants
des forces nommer les différents
représentants des unions fille au pair
sur les questions sécuritaires à des
troupes de maintien de la paix c'est
ainsi de suite en me basant notre
expérience je peux dire que la
réalisation de la stratégie était en
stage dans le cadre du goût droit
humanitaire
c'est ça ce qu'il faut pour renforcer
l'efficacité de notre travail
évidemment nous nous efforçons à nous
adapter pour chaque situation locale
concrètes
notre approche nos sens du comité
national de croix rouge
j ai travaillé avec les gens du doigt en
groupe y compris le groupe ethnique
nous opérons là où il ya des conflits
ensemble avec d'erreur forces armées
avec les autorités locales
nous favorisons les changes des
prisonniers la libération des personnes
détenues
ces fonds il est très important
d'assurer cette coopération étroite dans
ces questions comme le chant des
prisonniers de guerre les changes des
corps des victimes
ça c'est très important mais ça
nécessite la signature des accords le
processus de négociations un site
souvent on joue le rôle de médiateur
indépendant pour renforcer la confiance
entre les parties prenantes au mois
d'octobre au yémen plus d'un millier de
personnes ont été retenues vous êtes au
courant de cette situation là ça ne fait
qu'un petit exemple des opérations en
phase avec notre participation pour
résoudre ce conflit on a fait appel à
d'autres comme était en tant que média
ses rangs dépendant chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs
avant tout je tiens à mentionner dans le
cadre de notre travail nous serons nous
faisons guidée par des principes des
partenaires et vianne ce qui reste une
partie intégrante de notre travail pour
l'avenir les conflits qui surgissent
important caractère parfois en direct
sur moi maintenant on tire de tous les
conflits en reste avec la participation
de deux parties belligérantes et
vendeuses % des conflits peuvent
comprendre jusqu'à une dizaine une vie
voire une fontaine des parties
belligérantes et conflits sont tout à
fait différents actuellement toute cette
panoplie de conflit et d'observer un peu
partout dans le monde ce qui change le
paysage de notre partenariat drissi
auparavant juno stratégique
évidemment nous analysons les points
forts et les points faibles
nous allons les deux revendications des
parties belligérantes en essayant de
aider les gens qui en souffrent en
portant notre assistance et qu'on
persistance des moniteurs signifie que
chaque partenaire a un caractère
particulier représentent des risques et
des opportunités en contre et
l'essentiel c'est d'essayer de minimiser
les souffrances du mans c'est ça ce qui
emporte
alors il faut coopérer avec les gens qui
prennent les décisions
sur le terrain afin de minimiser les
risques et les affres des vases innocent
souvent l'absence de cohésion et de
l'approché intégrée nous empêche
d'attendre les résultats désirés
chaque fois que nous avons des
responsabilités rend peu floue et la
description des rôles des parties
belligérantes restant mal déterminées
nous avons du mal à atteindre nos
objectifs et diminuer les souffrances et
des affres de la population nous avons
des besoins concrets nous avons des
stratégies et qu'est ce que nous faisons
pour assurer un bon partenariat avec
lippi évidemment nous faut ce don à
l'analyse le tous les risques et des
conséquences pour la société civile nous
analysons ce qu'il faut faire pour mon
seulement serait de les relations et
poursuivre notre activité
il faut absolument prendre ses
responsabilités collectives pour aucune
nous puissions participer à la
résolution des conflits dans les quinze
autres mandats évidemment dans le cas de
violence de violation des accords il est
important d'apporter des mesures
correctives
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire encore
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait encore
évidemment faux à faire des spécialistes
militaires avec les représentants des
forces armées
on le fait pour faire partager notre
expertise dans le domaine de la
protection des populations civiles ce
qui s'avère encore champ pour assurer la
planification et la supervision des
conflits il n'y a pas longtemps nous
avons publié un article intitulé alliés
partenaires et parties tierces qui
[Musique]
explique notre opinion sur l'octroi de
l'aide humanitaire et des mécanismes ces
mendiants de partenariat que les parties
pdg rang
nous ne suivrons pas à publier les
articles paris nous prenons au des
oeuvres méthodologique crié honte ça
c'est être prises comme mode d'emploi à
en pratiquer pour planifier gérer et
analyser l et les opérations
humanitaires parfois militaires afin de
minimiser le sait les chefs français les
populations locales ne sommes évidemment
ouvert à toutes sortes de communication
coopération nous sommes heureux de
participer à des forums mac ont salué
dès aujourd'hui cette approche
d'ouverture et d'échangé favorable pour
tout le monde
le partenaire hier et ça fera mal pour
nous tous est favorable le bora le
succès d'autres causes et la protection
de la population innocente
durant le conflit tiens à mentionner que
notre comité international du coin rouge
toujours aux prêts à faire partager son
expérience à faire partager son avis
d'expert vécu des représentants des
forces armées
salut fis en pis aujourd'hui on parle de
l'afrique et du moyen rien c'est un
point sensible et douloureux et ce il
faut absolument éviter les souffrances
de la population innocente je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
surtout aux cours et pendant le temps de
crise le rôle des activités humanitaires
augmentent brusquement comme le nombre
de problèmes face au kiel et fonctionne
augmente aussi merci beaucoup des idées
très intéressantes et en nous souhaitons
une patience et une bonne détermination
une tenue un bon courage à votre
organisation
maintenant je suis ravi de passer la
parole au ministre défense de la
république du congo charles et richard
mondjo
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président de la conférence
cher conférencier mesdames et messieurs
je salue la tenue en présentiel de la
même conférence de moscou sur la
sécurité internationale
en dépit d'un contexte 35 marquée par la
crise a coronavirus la réflexion sur la
scène internationale demeure un
impératif vital pour la fédération de
russie et tous les états ici présents je
voudrais pour cela remercier les
autorités de la fédération de russie
pour avoir associé à plus du congo aux
présentes assises qu'elles trouvent ici
l'expression de notre sincère gratitude
cela dit ma contribution à la réflexion
sur ce thème général portera sur les
défis que pose la sécurité du domaine
maritime de la région afrique centrale
par contre c'est de l'accepter nationale
et mon collègue de la guinée équatoriale
on a abondamment parlé mesdames et
messieurs je disais récemment à une
occasion que la sécurité la sécurité
tant des dons défi notre société et de
notre siècle
malgré de multiples efforts déployés au
niveau international
continental et régional ce spectre des
conflits armés persiste cela nous
rappelle que la guerre a existé de tout
temps et que la paix sera toujours et
encore un état précaire sans cesse
menacée elle a évolué dans les objectifs
dans ses moyens et dans ses méthodes et
n'est plus le fait seul des états mais
aussi le plus souvent elle est portée
pas d orange un criminel qui est qu'une
nos territoires et s'affranchissent de
nos frontières
autant dire que la menace est globale et
permanente
elle se manifeste à travers les
violences le terrorisme le grand
banditisme et la criminalité la
piraterie maritime mettant ainsi en jeu
la sécurité globale du pays
face à ces menaces le congo un
patrimoine à défendre à savoir un
territoire en capital humain des
richesses et des institutions permettant
de mener à bien des aspirations de son
peuple
parlant de la sécurité nationale en plus
du concours
il me paraît sensé d'indiquer que notre
petit défense et de sécurité nationale
rassemble toutes les stratégies internes
de l'état pour préserver la paix sur
territoire de garantir la lune
syllogisme la libre circulation des
personnes et des biens et l'action des
institutions et leur pérennité
à cet égard elle a une portée à la fois
nationale et internationale mais aussi
régional pour ces raisons j'entends dans
mon intervention souligné la
sécurisation du domaine maritime
régionale d'afrique centrale dans le
continent stratégique
mr fleuve terre comme facteur
déterminant de la sécurité nationale en
république du congo qu'elle est mesdames
et messieurs le bilan de la protection
en mer et dans les eaux continentales
aujourd'hui dans notre pays et dans
notre sous-région la répu du convoi est
un état membre de la communauté que des
états d'afrique centrale ceeac et fait
partie de l'espace maritime dénommé
golfe de guinée et de l'espace fluvial
chargé de promouvoir
la navigation intérieure et la gestion
intégrée des ressources en eau qu'on
appelle bassin congo oubangui sanguin en
sigle cicos quel est l'état de la menace
au plan régional aujourd'hui le golfe de
guinée
un espace clé le commerce international
et le pétrole mondial d'entre eux c'est
la spirale la 7e réserve mondiale le gaz
nous mêmes réserves mondiales c'est donc
en espace stratégique pour les états de
la région et du monde
paradoxalement il constitue l'un des
principaux épicentre de la piraterie
maritime
on peut noter que depuis le début des
années 2000 le golfe de guinée connaît
un pic d'insécurité qui se traduit par
les prises d'otages l'arraisonnement des
navires les actes de malveillance et de
la piraterie qui ont occasionné des
pertes en vies humaines en produits
pétroliers en ressources halieutiques et
un niveau de violence
inquiétant pour la période biennale
2019-2020 le golfe de guinée a fait
l'objet en moyenne de 17 attaques de
navires 17 kidnapping des équipages qui
sont déroulés à la proche des côtes et
des eaux territoriales les objectifs les
moyens et les méthodes de ces criminels
se sont continuellement renforcé depuis
quelques temps quelle est la stratégie
collective pour lutter contre
l'insécurité en mer envie de lutter
contre cette insécurité les états de la
ceeac communauté économique de l'afrique
centrale se sont dotés en 2009
d'une stratégie commune de sécurisation
des intérêts des états au maire dit
protocole de kinshasa ce cadre a permis
notamment la mise en place d'un plan de
sécurisation en trois zones
d'intervention à savoir la zone à la
zone b dont fait partie le kumo et la
zone 10 une synergie a été établi entre
la commission du golfe de guinée
la communauté des états d'afrique
centrale et la communauté des états
d'afrique de l'ouest la cedeao visant la
mutualisation des efforts et les moyens
de sécurisation de ses espaces maritimes
commun l'adoption du code de conduite de
yaoundé en 2013 et la mise en place du
centre intervient de communication s'est
basé à yaoundé au cameroun ont rendu
nécessaire l'opération nisation des
structures de coordination de l'action
de l'état en mer des états ce dispositif
a posé les bases d'une coopération
interrégionale entre la cedeao par le
biais par le biais du centre régional de
sécurité maritime de l'afrique de
l'ouest créé ce maillot est là c'est
assez par le centre régional cité
maritime d'afrique centrale cosnac basée
à pointe noire en république du congo
de plus la charte africaine sur la
sécurité et la sûreté maritimes et
développement de l'afrique
adopté à lomé en 2015 offre un cadre
juridique de niveau continental pour
protéger les libéraux africain d'une
multiplication des crimes et des délits
en haute mer et sur les côtes maritimes
et promouvoir ainsi une bonne
gouvernance des espaces liquide du
continent la mise en oeuvre cette
stratégie est cependant confronté à
quelques goulot d'étranglement à
l'évidence
l'impact d'une manière négative sur
notre architecture de sûreté et de
sécurité maritime
cela a d'ailleurs fait l'objet d'une
réunion des milieux de la défense du
conseil de paix et de solidarité entre
le copax le 4 mai 2021
précédé par la deuxième réunion des
chefs d'état-major de la marine
nationale tenue le 29 avril 2021 porter
sur la sécurisation du domaine maritime
l'afrique centrale
les conclusions de cette réunion met en
exergue la nécessité pour les états
d'afrique centrale de mettre en place
des structures intégrées et mutualisée
de l'action de l'état en mer d'activer
le centre multi national de coordination
cnc de la zone à de mobiliser les
ressources pour le financement de la
sécurité maritime de disposer d'un bilan
global de partage des informations
maritime
mesdames et messieurs c'est aux
confluences des défis de sécurité dans
l'espace maritime
on partage que surgisse nos
préoccupations de sécurité nationale il
faut noter qu environ 80% de notre
richesse nationale provient de la mer
notre zone
notre domaine maritime qui s'étend des
eaux territoriales à la zone économique
exclusive soit environ 400 kilomètres de
la côte jusqu'à la haute mer et génère
beaucoup d'incidents et de convoitises
il en est de même pour la frange
fluviale qui s'étend sur 1200 km quelle
est la stratégie à mettre en oeuvre par
gouvernants congolais en vue de se
prémunir des diverses menaces sur les
côtes maritimes
la stratégie nationale de protection des
côtes maritimes congolaise est corrélée
à celle la frange fluvial elle est
structurée autour de l'action de l'état
en mer et dans les eaux continentales
pour permettre d'asseoir cette stratégie
d les efforts du gouvernement vise et
porte sur le cadre juridique les
ressources humaines les infrastructures
et les équipements
au plan juridique que faut-il faire et
qu'est ce qui a déjà été fait une loi
relative aux modalités de recours à la
coercition et à l'emploi de la force en
mer et dans les eaux continentales
publie en 2018 donne les moyens légaux
de lutte contre toutes menaces en mer et
sur les rues et sur le fleuve congo est
complète
cette loi les conventions
internationales sur la piraterie et
actes illicites en mer ratifié par
locaux
un décret portant organisation la
coordination de l'action de l'état en
mer règlement désormais des interactions
entre les acteurs du de l'action de
l'état en mer et de réseau continental
et ses acteurs concerne tous les
ministères qui sont liées à la gestion
de la mer au plan des ressources
humaines
la chute a tu représentes et requiert la
formation des personnels de toutes les
administrations intervenant en mer c'est
ainsi que les personnels militaires ont
été formés pour renforcer les capacités
opérationnelles de la marine nationale
placée elle au coeur du dispositif de
l'action de l'état en mer sa
participation régulière aux exercices
conjoints des forces navales au niveau
régional
actualise la connaissance opérationnelle
des forces dans un esprit de
progressivité dans l'appropriation des
savoirs faire et de savoir être
au plan des infrastructures et des
équipements nous renforçons les
capacités de surveillance côtière de
mobilité maritime et fluvial pour
assurer les patrouilles en haute mer et
sur le fleuve congo est en cours un
centre des opérations maritimes comme et
fonctionnels à pointe noire des centres
d'opération pluviales sont en cours
d'installation
quelles sont les perspectives l'enjeu de
la sécurisation du domaine maritime
congolais et d'y déployer un
environnement qui rassure et d'en faire
un espace attractif pour les navires
desservant les routes maritimes et
empruntant les routes maritimes du golfe
de guinée
les efforts entrepris au niveau de la
mer sont en articulation réel avec se
déployer la sécurisation du domaine
continentale et la france filiale de
sorte que la menace de qu'elle vienne
soit contrôlée grâce à une as à une
synergie d'actions entre les forces
navales et les forces terrestres
mesdames et messieurs la concrétisation
des défis de sécurité nationale est
tributaire de notre capacité entre
autres de l'ecsa de l'état de l'action
en mer et dans les eaux continentales un
domaine des synergies positives en
s'aidant de la coopération
internationale
c'est de cette façon coordonnée et
mutualisée au plan international que
nous pouvons faire face aux défis
sécuritaires de l'espace maritime dans
le golfe de guinée et garantir ainsi la
sécurité le développement d'autres pays
à partir des reggae richesse que procure
la mer et le fleuve
je souhaite ardemment l'avènement une
coalition navale contre la piraterie en
mer
couplé à une interaction opérationnelles
terrestres afin que pèse sur les
criminels maritime une vraie pression
une vraie menace à leur mouvement en
s'appuyant sur le droit international
je voudrais réitérer ici la volonté de
notre chef d'état son excellence
monsieur denis sassou n'guesso présent
la république du congo
de tenir ses engagements pour maintenir
notre espace maritime communautaires
dans les conditions de sûreté et de
sécurité permettant l'exercice des
activités légales diverses lui qui
assure aujourd'hui la présidence
tournante de l'organisation régionale
là c'est assez dans cette perspective
une plaie de situer la part que devrait
prendre la fédération de russie dans
cette lutte contre la piraterie maritime
à laquelle les pays du golfe de guinée
font face aujourd'hui l'un spérian de la
russie pays une tradition maritime n'est
plus à démontrer en la matière
ça présente sa précieuse contribution
dans les radicaux de la piraterie
maritime dans le golfe d'aden est assez
illustrative pour laisser penser que la
coopération des pays de la région avec
la fédération de russie dans ce domaine
aurait vocation à être un nikci de
construction de la sécurité
internationales la mise en oeuvre la
stature de sécurité maritime de raffi
son talent est ouverte à ce type de
coopération puisse la même conférence
sur la sécurité internationale renforcer
notre plaidoyer en faveur des réponses
encore plus adapté à apporter aux
différentes menaces venant de la mer et
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup messieurs les ministres
c'est tout à fait vrai la russie c'est
un pays qui est de longue tradition
maritime
quant à moi personnellement je suis pas
spécialiste mais je pense que si la
russie commence à s'occuper de près des
pirates l'art et ils vont disparaître
bientôt je pense que vous êtes bien
adressé je pense que mes collègues du
ministère de la défense pourrait
développer ce sujet j'aimerais surtout
pour vous remercier pour le fait que
vous avez abordé ce sujet la terre et la
mer parce que cette année il ya deux
mois nous avons dû phénomène intéressant
ou importe cargo a été bloquée dans le
dans la voix dans le canal de suez
et pendant ce blocage la finlande par
exemple commencer à vous et le manque et
du café et on a compris et surtout
l'interaction de tous ces voiliers de
liaison les fleuves les rivières le sent
la terre et surtout la pandémie a
souligné tout s'est fait parce que d'une
part nous sommes isolés
d'autre part ne pouvons pas un saint
passé merci beaucoup d'avoir appelé se
pète et maintenant j'aimerais passer la
parole au ministre d'état chargé des
affaires du président de la république
de guinée monsieur dia
ap
monsieur le modérateur mesdames et
messieurs c'est un honneur pour moi
le partage et la 9e conférence de moscou
sur la sécurisation internationale et
surtout un privilège de prendre la
parole
excusez moi je disais que c'est un
honneur pour moi de partager ou de
participer à la 9e conférence de moscou
sur la sécurité internationale et
surtout un privilège de prendre la
parole à cette tribune pour intervenir
sur la coopération militaire et militaro
technique entre la russie et les pays de
l'afrique et du moyen orient facteur
principal de renforcement de la sécurité
régionale
car des pays africains en général je
remercie son excellence le général
d'armée sergey sékou ministre la défense
la fédération de russie pour
l'opportunité que son invitation m'offre
le prendre part avec ma délégation à ce
forum international qui a bien voulu
organiser encore cette année malgré la
conjoncture sanitaire international
toujours très éprouvante
j'en profite pour m'acquitter d'un
devoir qui est celui de prix son
excellence monsieur le ministre la
défense de la fédération de russie de
transmettre les chaleureuses salutations
de son excellence monsieur le président
de la république le professeur alpha
condé chef d'état sa suprême des armées
à jean frère et ami son excellence
monsieur
mieux poutine président de la fédération
de russie en effet l'honneur qui est
fait à mon pays d'être le nouveau
représentée à cette plateforme
d'échangés témoigne de l'excellence des
relations d'amitié et de coopération qui
existent entre nos deux états depuis
l'accession de notre pays à
l'indépendance nationale le 28 le 2
octobre 1958
c'est pourquoi son excellence monsieur
le président de la république m'a
particulièrement chargé de réaffirmer à
son excellence monsieur le président de
la fédération de russie sa volonté
ardente le perpétuer ces relations en
vue du progrès de nos deux pays
mesdames et messieurs pour revenir à
l'objet de notre rencontre je voudrais
exprimer ici toute ma reconnaissance aux
mines et celle de la défense de la
fédération de russie pour l'opportunité
que nous offre la conférence le moscow
d'échangés périodiquement sur la
problématique de la sécurité
internationale qui se posent toujours au
monde avec plus d'acuité
malgré les initiatives et les efforts
des états
les progrès technologiques et
scientifiques nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans un ordre mondial où les menaces
sont diffuses et imprévisible mal marqué
par un environnement de volonté
d'incertitude de complexité et dames
vérité en afrique la sécurité globale de
nos états est de plus en plus menacés
par les crises politiques liées
nos processus démocratique et à
l'exacerbation de la pauvreté du chômage
qui favorise les revendications sociales
la radicalisation religieuse le
terrorisme l'extrémisme violent
les rébellions armées les conflits
communautaires et séparatistes la
criminalité organisée
les épidémies et pandémies qui viennent
s'ajouter aux calamités naturelles au
coco gênante pressoir des déplacements
massifs des populations nos ensembles
sous régionaux sont confrontés chacun à
un ou plusieurs de ces défis
sécuritaires spécifiques
depuis la déstabilisation de la libye
l'instabilité contagieuse dans la bande
sahélo saharienne et la persistance de
boer g dans le bassin du câble de lacq
en interviews analyses et le terrorisme
et l'extrémisme violent en afrique
occidentale et centrale
la bande sahélo saharienne est devenu
d'incendiaires le groupe armé terroriste
et du trafic de tout genre une geôle
imprenable d'où les dyades east veulent
partir pour étendre leur empire jusqu'à
là jusqu'au col feu de la guinée
le la corne de l'afrique
toujours emploi de la piraterie maritime
est un autre foyer de tension entretenu
par les cheer up qui déstabilise la
somalie et le kenya
plusieurs autres pays de la côte est de
l'afrique comme la tanzanie et le
mozambique sont aussi victimes d'
attaque terroriste
la prolifération et la circulation
illicite des armes légères et de petit
calibre résultats des différents
conflits favorise la reconnaissance des
roubaisiens fratricide avec leurs
massacres de civils dans les pays des
grands lacs et dans le bassin du lac
tchad
plus récemment en plus les crises post
électorales qui ont secoué certains pays
de l'afrique de l'ouest la guerre de
sécession en ethiopie et la rébellion au
tchad et a coûté la vie au président
idriss deby itno constituent des motifs
de préoccupation dans les effets
risquent de faire basculer ses parties
du continent dans une insécurité
généralisée au delà des pays du g5 sahel
le cameroun et le nigeria sont
périodiquement victimes d'attaqués
meutrières qui endeuillent le pays et
provoque les déplacements massifs des
populations
tous ces foyers de tension et la guerre
qui sèment la terreur à rendre les états
de plus en plus instable et
compromettent la mise en oeuvre les
programmes de développement socio
économique
cet état de fait augmente le taux de
pauvreté et de chômage exacerbe les
tensions sociales effet de l'afrique un
réservoir potentiel de candidats à la
migration clandestine dans l'ampleur
devient incontrôlable la russie il faut
s'en féliciter appuie les pays africains
dans la gestion de ces conflits dans le
cadre de ses relations de coopération
militaire bilatérale mais aussi dans
celui de l'intervention de la communauté
internationale à travers les nations
unies depuis la création de son armée le
1er novembre 1958 la république de
guinée entretient une coopération
militaire privilégié avec la russie
cette coopération militaire aux côtés
des autres partenaires techniques et
financiers accompagne le processus de la
réforme du secteur de sécurité ont
craché sous la conduite du président de
la république le professeur alpha condé
depuis son accession à la magistrature
suprême de notre pays
l'un des avantages de cette réforme de
l'armée guinéenne et la reprise de la
place de notre pays sur la scène
internationale dans le domaine des
opérations le maintien de la paix avec
l'envoi des contingents militaires
depuis plusieurs années au sein de la
mission multi dimensionnelle intégré des
nations unies pour la stabilité la
ministre la stabilité du mali la mini
sma et des observateurs militaires ou de
sécurité au compte des nations unies
pour maintenir l'élan de cette
participation
notre pays dispose d'un centre
d'entraînement aux opérations de
maintien de la paix
qui qui ambitionne de devenir un centre
sous régional avec l'appui technique
les partenaires financiers mesdames et
messieurs la construction les armées
nationales fortes en afrique se heurte
aux contrats existants avec la volonté
politique des dirigeants et les
capacités économiques des états cette
situation est aggravée par les crises de
tout genre qui agitent le monde
d'autant plus que l'adaptation des
équipements des armées au niveau
contexte sécuritaire souffle de
l'insuffisance des moyens financiers
nécessaires à la mise en oeuvre des lois
de programmation militaire
élaboré à cet effet en conséquence de
nombreuses armées africaines sont dans
l'incapacité de gérer par elle même
n'est moindre menace sécuritaire
compromettant ainsi la stabilité socio
économique et politique de leur pays
avec des incidences dommageable à
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale
d'où l'obligation de la mutualisation
plus accueilli des efforts de toute la
communauté internationale
au delà des idéologies et de la
géopolitique
c'est la seule alternative
aujourd'hui ceci est la seule
alternative aujourd'hui qui peut amener
le monde avec les forces du mal qui
s'identifie par la radicalisation de la
guerre la violence la terreur
le trafic de tout genre
c'est pourquoi l'afrique en plus de la
nécessité de la montée en puissance des
armées nationales a et préoccupations
longtemps exprimé de création et
d'opérationnalisation d'une force en
attente de l'union africaine avec des
composantes sous régionale
il est évident
que la montée en puissance d'une telle
force permettra au continent africain de
disposer des unités d'intervention
capable de prévenir et de gérer
efficacement toute la situation de
conflit qui déstabilise nos états
la matérialisation de telles initiatives
nécessitent une coopération militaire
multidimensionnelle plus remplacés entre
les pays africains et les puissances
militaires comme la russie en termes de
renforcement des capacités en matière de
formation et surtout d'équipements
majeurs adaptée au contexte sécuritaire
actuelle
cette approche permettra aux grandes
puissances d'économiser les moins
mobilisés pour leur intervention
militaire d'urgence visant à sauver les
états africains du péril terroriste
telle que l'opération serval au mali
cette nouvelle forme de coopération
militaire appelé de tous les voeux par
l'afrique devrait trouver aujourd'hui un
écho favorable auprès des puissances
militaires à travers des rencontres
comme la conférence de moscou sur la
sécurité internationale
mesdames et messieurs au régal de tous
les facteurs qui génèrent les conflits
la restauration de la sécurité
internationale et la consolidation de la
paix doit aussi inclure une nouvelle
forme de coopération internationale axée
sur l'accroissement et de l'appui au
développement économique et technique
aux états africains
c'est dire que la coopération avec les
puissances militaires loi tendre
désormais vers cette réalité implacable
pour que les efforts de lutte pour la
consolidation de la paix revêtent un
caractère efficace et durable
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
populations par la réduction de la
disparité le partage de la prospérité
sont autant de facteurs qui peuvent
empêcher les couches défavorisées de se
radicaliser de se masser aux portes de
l'europe où le s'enrôler dans les
conflits qui sont souvent par les leurs
sans avoir été exhaustif il le voudrait
terminer mon intervention sur une note
d'espoir en faveur de la prise en compte
de cette nouvelle conception de la
coopération en vue de mieux faire face
aux défis sécuritaires contemporaine
je réclame jeu
réaffirme ici la disponibilité de mon
pays a dynamisé chaque jour davantage
cette coopération avec la fédération de
russie dans le cadre la préservation de
la paix de la stabilité et de la
sécurité internationales pour l'intérêt
supérieur des états et des peuples
vivent la coopération internationale
vive la paix et la sécurité
internationales
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci je remercie votre excellence pour
cette intervention pleine d'espoir et
couvre n'avoir nous avoir rappelé des
problèmes de l'afrique centrale il y a
pas longtemps pas fait des mois que très
jeune histoire avec les présidents du
tchad kenya aux élections et à l'éthique
tué au front en combattant les
terroristes côté c'est un tragédie et de
l'autre côté on peut dire que ce gameiro
isme qu'on trouve dans les oeuvres
littéraires à parmi les meilleurs je
remercie je tiens à remercier peter
maurer pour sa participation en lorraine
qui était peu pratique et un entretien
prévu pour d'armé et comme le disent nos
adversaires stratégique
les derniers mais pour le moment c'est
le général lorsqu'avec le
les directeurs de la direction
opérationnelle du l'état majeur de
l'état major général des forces armées
de l'opération dort ici
mesdames et messiers dans mon
intervention je vais parler plus en
détail sur la situation syrienne pour
[Musique]
mettre à jour le rôle joué par les
acteurs régionaux extra région
actuellement la situation dans la
république de syrie contre les en
général par le gouvernement syrien
l'intégration de russie a déployé les
efforts à poursuivre la stabilisation de
la situation locale et assisterez à la
lutte contre le terrorisme international
sur le territoire syrien a défendu
risquerait la vie civile ont passage des
opérations de déminage dsi
d'infrastructure importants et sensibles
ont réalisé programme d'aidé humanitaire
de restauration de l'infrastructure des
transports en conducteur à part de
l'activité de notre groupe paul ancien
lycée la contribution au rapatriement
des réfugiés et des personnes je forçais
se déplacer nous sommes actifs eu à
travailler vers résolution de crise la
crise à sienne dans le cadre de forme at
astana dont la future réunion est prévue
pour le 6 juillet dans la cellule et
north et à rien pour régler la situation
dans les zones des escales à l'iran si
on continue
née patrouiller avec nos collègues turcs
la zone de l'euphrate orientale pour
éviter les hostilités entre avec les
groupements en cure kurdes ont ici
ensemble on réalise ce travail en même
temps certains facteurs ont une négation
influence négative au processus de
règlement du conflit dans la zone mena
d'escaladé libre on trouve en nombre des
combattants dont plus de dix tonnes ils
sont des participants actifs des
organisations terroristes
internationales
leur leader ne renonce pas à leur projet
revanchard de reprendre leur influence
sur le territoire syrien
il utilise les moyens le plus court des
attaques terroristes contre les civils à
des bombardements des mille et uns des
attaques et contre les forces
gouvernementales ornementale dans la
zone on cultive les aider d'islam
radical ont interdit toute sorte des
manifestations de la vie civique
concéder des exactions aux violences aux
exécutions démonstrative et ce mr ceux
qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
l'idéologie des terroristes les cours
extraire illicitement et à vendre les
hydrocarbures et ferme les yeux
or du conflit un couvent savez
force toujours 2es avec les tribus
arabes qui sont contre le pillage des
ressources naturelles ciani recrutement
coercive d'un désert à bord des groupes
armés tour gestion plus aux douloureuses
parmi les camps de réfugiés et bd
signalé dans le sens dole qui se
trouvent sur le territoire contrôlé par
les forces démocratiques et céline la
situation lamentable des réfugiés
le contexte de crise y est humanitaire
et physiologique dans l'eau quand le
surpeuplement et à l'absence des
perspectives de résolution de ce
problème à contribuer au recrutement
monde par les terroristes n'est des
combattants parmi les habitants de
substances de l'été étant et on trouvera
le camp de réfugiés russes ban où la
situation reste très tendue à partir de
février 2010 9 ans les troupes russes
ensemble avec les marges le gouvernement
saignant ensemble avec l'onu et le
croissant rouge en syrie ont val d'izé
des troubles et pour la liquidation de
ce camp qui hébergeait devant 6000
personnes au résultat de ce travail on
ne construit que 4000 personnes dans
seulement 400 ha sont des réfugiés le
reste ce sont des rets du coq et les
membres de leur famille sentant leur en
se sentant sécurisé sous sa protection
des états unis et de leurs alliés les
les terroristes se sentent invincibles
ni comment ça sans filtre sur les
territoires avoisinantes
parfois les terroristes à son guide et
par leurs auteurs occidentaux en
réalisant des mesures de déstabilisation
de la situation au sud de la série las
de césar
or adoptée par les états unis exercent à
l'affluence négatives sur la
normalisation de la situation économique
et dans le pays
honda se prétend que cet acte vise les
gouvernements des filles mais en prédire
saisissent les citoyen syrien en
dégradant leurs situations quotidiennes
et leur situation financière
les lectrices objectifs de cette
politique
c'est à faire dégrader le niveau de vie
du peuple syrien en renforçant le
potentiel de protestation visant à
déstabiliser la situation politique dans
le pays ont fait du des élections
présidentielles tenues le vent ciné de
la mère news qui ont démontré le soutien
en quasi unanimement par le peuple des
activités du chef de l'état il faut
s'attendre à un renforcement de la
pression les sanctions de la part des
états occidentaux dans le domaine
humanitaire et économique à cette
optique les pas entrepris par les états
unis lé d'henrique au docteur terrien
son gant des déclarations faites par
washington dans le petit qui est de la
lutte contre le des ch en profitant des
secteurs de la frontière
en dehors du contrôle des gouvernements
seniors qui sont les frontières avec la
turquie et l'iran via jordanie et
terroristes se déplacent librement de la
syrie vers d'autres pays du
rien en entrant trafic important des
réducs ou vise l'afghanistan et le
continent européen
on signale à ce débat qu'un culte et des
combattants de daytona qu'amis temps les
combattants de dèche continue à déployer
le réseau de leur cellule de rim en
juillet mais n'a au contexte du conflit
les terres pouvant les puristes du de
l'antenne de l'aisne qaïda à renforcent
leur influence et le secteur de leurs
activités en afrique à la situation de
la plus tendue reste dans les plis des
zones je sais qu'elles saignent et dans
la partie est du continent où les
combattants a tourist renforcent leurs
positions et entraîne les tentatives de
talent et de pouvoir dont les
intervenants précédents ont déjà
beaucoup parler en général une faible
coordination des avides et l'activité de
la communauté internationale dans leur
jeunesse dans le domaine de la lutte
contre la menace terroriste
les tentatives de ces entreprises par
certains pays et de déstabiliser les
cieux
voyant que rien en créant de nouveaux
longs de conflit le renforcement de la
pression
5 suaire sanctions contribuer à
radicaliser la population et à faire le
transfert de l'eau traitée au risque
dans les régions voisines
l'implication de la communauté
internationale dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme à permettrait de favoriser la
sécurité internationale encore les ports
ou comment je vais remet ici de votre
attention
merci c'est c'est pour ça que nous
adorons le nail conférence du ministère
de la france et la possibilité
d'entendre les informations
intéressantes ça de la part des speakers
légué plastique
je tiens à souligner que vous pouvez
prendre connaissance sort de l'adresse
des ministres de la défense de la
république et syrienne ce discours est
disponible dans notre site internet
je remercie tous les participants jeunes
excusé pour ce retard croyez-moi
volontaire à la pause serait courte une
dizaine de minutes essais en dix minutes
on vous attend pour reprendre le travail
je vous remercie de votre attention le
prochain match est ce possible